there's a fascinating organization
called Maps multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies this
is a non-profit think tank that
advocates for the responsible
investigation of psychedelic plants and
chemicals and exploring their potential
as tools for transformation for
interpersonal transformation right and
this is a moment that we're living in
now right we're kind of living through a
psychedelic Renaissance where all of a
sudden people are starting to take these
tools these cognitive technologies that
have been used for thousands of years a
little more seriously we're starting to
take out the magnifying glass and stop
being alarmist and actually paying
attention and studying tool the
potential of these tools right so
there's a fascinating article written by
Timothy Leary back in the 60s called
programming the psychedelic experience
and the idea here was that if you could
successfully pattern and sequence the
input signals that the subject would
receive when he was on a psychedelic
Odyssey you could literally assure
functional output you could almost
guarantee a functional catharsis that
there would be value to the psychedelic
session and he described the psychedelic
experience as a period of increased
reactivity to stimuli both from within
and from without so you are immediately
plunged into a dialogue with your own
subconscious
things start to erupt things start to
emerge new patterns are start start to
be perceived at the same time the world
becomes like a Sensurround system you
know the fidelity the resolution of the
input signals dead boosted so all of a
sudden you are overwhelmed almost
eclipsed by the signals coming in you
are like a mind in flight you are in
orbital position you are seeing the big
picture but if you don't have navigation
if you don't pattern those signals by
carefully choosing
music by carefully curating expecially
ecstatic
referee's that you can read while you
are tripping you know controlling the
environment
hanging around people that whose company
induces feelings of well-being by
patterning their singles your authoring
this song just the soul surfing that
you're actually doing people that engage
in these mystical states are known as
Psychonauts they're literally soul
surfers investigating psyche through
first-person experience and there's all
kinds of answers that we can find within
there's all kind of spaces that you can
explore the new space is inner space is
fascinating we look deeper into this
mystery wanting to explore these
numinous grounds these archetypical
realms from within you need to go Carl
you'll and our own brains using a
cocktail of chemical
thrust the body-mind into luminal spaces
of exploration we need to engineer
inception light dreams faces to explore
and the technologies not all going to be
external some of them are going to be
internal you know computers are drugs
but drugs are computers this is the
essence and this driver should be open
to this stuff because it's absolutely
fascinating
check out maps multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies